the winning won't stop can't stop won't
stop following up on shredding the Iran
nuclear deal and freeing American
hostages in North Korea the Trump
administration has captured five of the
top commanders of Isis plus were winning
the culture Bigley then James O'Keefe
talks about his latest sting to take
down the teacher unions finally the mail
bag on michael knowles and this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh hello there hello sorry I was just
catching up on a little light reading
this would be reasons to vote for
Democrats a comprehensive guide and it's
a little it's so bright the future is so
bright that I'm not only do I have to
wear shades I have to wear my make
America great again hat that's how good
this week is it's you know we have so
much to get to today I'll leave it on
that's fun
we have so much to get to today so I'm
gonna have to go through it very quickly
because we're also gonna be talking to
James O'Keefe about a phenomenal sting
operation basically you know all of the
journalists in America have stopped
doing their job and so conservative
people with video cameras have become
the only real journalists we'll talk to
James about that really breaking a break
ground breaking stuff you thought it was
over you thought it was all over didn't
you this week you thought ok we shredded
the Iran nuclear deal we've returned
American hostages from North Korea we've
practically destroyed Barack Obama's
legacy that's enough that's enough for
one week right that's enough no it isn't
enough ha ha ha because there's one
aspect of Barack Obama's foreign policy
legacy that is still sort of standing
and that would be Isis know that I'm
sorry what's that I once I'm trying to
finish the show you see Isis isn't what
oh I'm sorry
five top leaders of Isis have been
captured in a u.s. Iraqi coalition plus
all one ally thought we a top aide to
Isis leader Abu Bakr al Baghdadi can't
this week is like they should have saved
this for the week before the midterm
elections because it's it's almost too
perfect how these stories have just
fallen so the United States has
virtually decapitated Isis as the cherry
on top of Barack Obama's terrible
horrible no good very bad week for
comment let's turn to former President
Barack Obama I know I'm sorry mr.
president I'm sorry let's talk to all of
all about this before we get to it I
have to thank a wonderful sponsor the
zip recruiter zip recruiter is really
good I got to tell you if you're hiring
every business needs great people and a
better way to find those great people
something better than just posting your
job online and praying for the right
people to see it you know in the old
days but back when I got my job here at
the Daily wire the way we would hire
people as we'd go to insane asylums and
just collect people with a big Zamboni
that we're just lying around on the
sidewalk screaming in the air so that's
how we did it for the first little while
didn't work out grow I'm glad that I got
here but it didn't work out great for
everybody now we as a zip recruiter zip
recruiter is so so good
zip recruiter knew there's a smarter way
so they built a platform that finds the
right job candidates for you it learns
what you're looking for it identifies
people with the right experience that
invites them to apply to your job so
it's not just posting on a job board
it's actually you're gonna post that job
and it is gonna go out and find the
candidates that you should be looking at
it's gonna do all of that for you that's
why 80% of employers who post a job on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site in just one day the zip
recruiter doesn't just stop there they
even spotlight the strongest
applications that you receive so you
never miss a great match so not only
does it find you the great candidates
for that your job it's going to
highlight which of the applicants are
the best for you there's nothing like
this you have to use if recruiter
businesses of all sizes trust that
Prakriti for their hiring needs right
now right now listen I know we're a
we're a certain kind of vision of the
world show and so we've got very
entrepreneurial people who watch this
use zip recruiter my listeners can try
zip recruiter for free that is right for
free go to zip recruiter comm slash MKS
zip recruiter comm slash MKS zip
recruiter dot-com slash MKS sip
recruiter smarter way to hire okay
the winning won't stop we just spoke
with the former President Barack Obama
it's been a banner week for Republicans
and a brutal one for Democrats brutal
politically and culturally so we're
gonna run through it as quickly as we
can before we get to James Barak Obama
created the conditions that led to Isis
taking over Iraq and Syria
Barack Obama then failed to fight Isis
and Barack Obama then called Isis the JV
team in 2014 to try to downplay it it's
not a big deal let me here let me get
some sand and bury my head in it here is
the exact quote from the former
president
President Obama speaking about America's
deadliest enemies his choice of war is
getting a lot of attention in an
interview with The New Yorker magazine
he compares groups linked to al-qaeda to
an amateur basketball team quote the
analogy we use around here sometimes and
I think is accurate is if a JV team
meaning junior varsity team puts on
Lakers uniforms that doesn't make them
Kobe Bryant end quote
that's Barack Obama wants to pretend
that he's not referring to Isis I had to
take the hat off because I rely on my
hair for about four inches of my height
you know I got some kind of poofy hair
so we had to lose the Hat but it's still
living within me the mag the khofifah is
within you so Obama tried to say I oh no
that I wasn't calling Isis JV oh no no
even PolitiFact even left-leaning
politifact says absolutely he was
referring to Isis then Barack Obama
starts to call that group Isis ISIL the
Islamic State of Iraq and the Levant
that whole region and the reason that
they did that the reason the entire
Obama administration called it ISIL when
everybody else referred to it as Isis is
because Isis the Islamic State of Iraq
and Syria as it's called in the in the
english-speaking world Isis highlights
the foreign policy failures of Barack
Obama Barack Obama chose to lose the war
in Iraq which we had already won chose
not to get a Status of Forces Agreement
that country fell apart Isis took over
Barack Obama made empty threats in Syria
his his foreign policy was utterly
bungled utterly weak he wouldn't enforce
red lines and Syria fell to Isis so when
you even the word Isis might as well be
called the Islamic state of all of
Barack Obama's failures so they couldn't
do that they had to try to change the
name but a rose by any other name and an
Islamic militant group by any other name
is just as deadly and just as must must
be taken care of just as much so that
that JV team that Barack Obama referred
to they didn't do anything right they're
not Kobe Bryant they didn't accept they
killed 38 Europeans at a Tunisian resort
they bombed Turkey killed 33 Tunisia
again killed 24 foreign tourists crashed
a Russian flight killed 224 people on
that bombed Ankara bombed Beirut
slaughtered 130 in Paris slaughtered 86
and niece killed 12 in Berlin bombed the
mansion
Karina in the UK that's not even a
fraction of the attacks that Isis is
caused but the obama says no it JV
it's JV hey don't look hey don't look
over there don't believe your lyin eyes
don't no no they're not they're not a
threat so the Obama administration did
very very little to stop them then in
comes Donald Trump and the other
Republican candidates campaigned on this
probably Donald Trump more than anybody
he campaigned on utterly destroying Isis
then when he became president he
empowered the military to do it he
routed Isis out of its geographic
stronghold last year now he's basically
decapitated the entire organization it's
interesting that they're reporting on
the five Isis commanders that we've
captured you know Obama liked to just
drone them out of the sky because it's
relatively risk-free but it's much
better to capture them so that you can
get intelligence out of them
nevertheless it's much more politically
risky because if one of your servicemen
is shot or killed at Kerry's political
risk so Obama went for the easy way out
and the Trump administration has gone in
and captured five of these people but
the number is actually six because we
also captured a top aide to Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi the leader of Isis so why is
the five number important here you might
recall that Barack Obama released that
the Taliban five I think they were
called right these these five Islamic
militants he just released them out of
Gitmo for no reason at all he just
released them so that he could try to
close down Guantanamo Bay very dangerous
people who can be back on the
battlefield he released five Muslim
terrorists Donald Trump captures five
Muslim terrorists they're really at six
because we the United States and Iraq
captured a top aide then he used that
top aide to lure out five of his little
buddies among whom were the head of a
major Isis territory and the head of
Isis internal security so much for
internal security guess that guy wasn't
so good at his job
he's like the Barack Obama of internal
security organizations right it just
didn't didn't quite do it right didn't
didn't live up to his job this is the
classic dichotomy we've seen in the last
year-and-a-half
Barack Obama says something can't be
done Barack Obama's administration can't
do it Donald Trump completely does it
within a year and a half
speaking of places where Obama failed
and Trump succeeded last night Donald
Trump showed up
to greet the hostages that his
administration freed from North Korea
here's President trumpet and the
hostages the fact that we were able to
get him out so soon was really a tribute
to a lot of things including a certain
process that's taking place right now
and that process is very important so we
will see what happens we have a meeting
scheduled in a very short period of time
you'll be hearing about it sir we have
the location set and we will see if we
can do something that people did not
think was going to happen for many many
years and a lot of bad things could have
happened in between so I just want to
say this is a special night for these
three really great people and
congratulations on being in this country
thank you
congratulations on being in this country
because being in this country is a great
great thing and the people who have been
deprived of that know that even if
Americans particularly who wear those
pink hats and the screech and shout even
if they don't fully appreciate it
President Trump says that really bad
things could have happened what do I
think what he's referring to is Hillary
Clinton could have been elected
president and then we wouldn't be seeing
these hostages home very low probability
that we would have something I noted - I
noticed but I forgot to note yesterday
this happened at 2:00 a.m. Donald Trump
met them at 2:00 a.m. when they they got
off their airplane and he wrote about
this he tweeted I'm gonna be there at
2:00 a.m. I'm gonna show up at 2:00 a.m.
he's all full of energy at 2:00 a.m. the
Reid Ahnold Trump is a media manipulator
he knows what he's doing in the media
this is not to say he's met her niek and
playing 25 dimensional chess but he
really knows what he's doing in the
media this 2 a.m. thing is a snub at
Hillary Clinton because for years
Hillary Clinton said who do you want to
answer the phone at 3:00 a.m. who do you
want that's me I'm gonna answer the
phone at 3:00 a.m. right of course when
she was called at 3:00 a.m. with in
Benghazi and when she lost the election
she didn't pick up but what Donald Trump
is saying is 2 a.m. 2 a.m. at middle of
the night happened I'm here the hostages
have all thanked Donald Trump imagine
imagine that you are one of these
hostages was held for a pretty long time
some of the other ones are more recently
2017 and afterward one of the hostages
Kim dong-chul was arrested in October
2015 sentenced to 10 years of hard labor
imagine just imagine this you are Kim
dong-chul you've been in a North Korean
prison since 2015 then some guy named
Mike Pompeo shows up and he says you're
coming back to America you haven't
you've been in prison now for three
years and this guy Mike who are you Mike
Pompeo I'm the CIA director oh yeah okay
who's the president who's the president
who got me freed of this prison Donald
Trump I would send me I his head must
have exploded what do you say I'm
clearly I'm in prison I clearly AM in a
fantasy land right now unbelievable
we will get to what this means for
Barack Obama in just one second I have
to thank blue apron a wonderful really
wonderful sponsor of the show that I was
just eating about 12 hours ago
I
this is like all I eat anymore as blue
apron it is so so good blue apron is the
leading meal delivery kit service in the
u.s. well many people know what they do
you you probably don't know the kinds of
meals that you get these meals are
delicious I really mean it this is
almost all that I eat anymore
especially because I have sweet little
and Lisa to cook them you know and the
sweet little ace is not included when
you subscribe by the way blue apron is
the number one a fresh ingredient recipe
delivery service in the country you're
not just gonna get a cheeseburger or
something you're gonna get short rib
burgers with a hoppy cheddar sauce on a
pretzel bun you're gonna get seared
steaks and thyme pan sauce green beans
crispy shallots it's all really good
it's all really really good you can get
the two-person meal plan it actually it
is enough food it's never enough food
for acavano go phone could sit there
like a dog and eat all night it they
actually give you good portions and
they're they're really high quality
ingredients and food you get the
two-person meal plan if you're a big
Kevon you you know you should get the
you should get the 25 person meal plan
you know then you get you through the
night you get eight recipes per week
with the choice to receive either two or
three recipes any week the family meal
plan that serves four people or the wine
plan six bottles of wine from renowned
wine makers delivered monthly that could
get you through breakfast really good
meals last night I had this really good
thing it was trout with rice and its
really good sauce really really good
right now let me buy you a free food
take you would be in the same and
foolish not to take me up on this offer
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free at blue apron
calm /co FFA co v fe fe i know you might
feel like you've been just OD'ing on CAF
fi all week it's been a really good week
for that go top it off put the cherry on
top at blue apron blue apron calm / co
FFA co v fe fe blue apron a better way
to cook barack obama actually admitted
that his administration is terrible on
hostages
you you have to realize right now all
the mainstream media wants to do is
cover up cover up cover up all that they
have all of the terrible obama
administration and how good donald
trump's been fortunately we have tape
barack obama said quote it is true that
there have been times where our
government regardless of good intentions
has let them down
meaning prisoners overseas and hostages
I promised them that we can do better
but you didn't do better Barack you
didn't do better Donald Trump did better
you made a mess he cleaned it up we've
talked about Iran there's much more to
talk about with Iran we'll have to save
that for next week before we get to
James I just want to mention one little
bit on the culture a word on the culture
right now so maybe you're familiar with
the website click whole click whole is
it's one of these sites like the onion
it's a satire site of kind of the news
and all that it's this it's like the
onion of BuzzFeed that's one of these
internet satire sites right this is a
barometer of the culture they click
whole has launched a new website called
a resistance hole and some of the
headlines on it are mr. drum your newest
nightmare is a website called resistance
hole and the whole site is parodying the
left-wing resistance the anti Trump
crowd on the Left they're ridiculing
them because those people are ridiculous
one of these articles goes for too long
mr. president you've been destroying our
country from the inside out with your
lies and your treasons and most shameful
of all your rude tweets it's perfectly
understanding that the left and part of
the Pearl clutching right is they're
getting all worked up over these little
tweets over these little social faux pas
this would not be in look if this were a
conservative website that we're doing it
I'd say it's funny satire but not a big
deal this is a totally mainstream satire
website look we've seen Kanye West oh
shift the culture massively the pop
culture massively in an openness to free
thought in an openness to the Republican
President we've seen and we've seen the
effect of that on public polling major
moves in opinion polling but this is the
mainstream cracking and finally saying
look those people in the pink hats are
ridiculous we have to make fun of them
another headline on the website game
over Trump an ancient order of
Franciscan monks has released a 13th
century tapestry depicting Donald Trump
colluding with the Russians
that is that's funny because the left
has become insane with this Russia
conspiracy theory they've been running
with it forever and now it is ridiculous
you're seeing the culture crack this is
a really really good movie this is this
is as important as any story or reading
in politics this week because politics
is down
of culture and this is a harbinger of
good things to come you know they have
another one - they have one making fun
of the right - it's called Patriot hole
but that's there always websites making
fun of the right that there is now a
basically left-wing publication mocking
the left that's phenomenal that is a
great great news we're joined now by
James O'Keefe I've spoke with James a
couple days ago about this incredible
video of his here's the latest sting
operation from Project Veritas great
journalists who go and expose left-wing
organizations when the mainstream media
won't do it here is his part of his
latest video I got people who want drugs
and she five times was fired and I got
her job back five times but it's my job
it's almost like being at the priest
it's my job to protect listen if you hit
me kid
it is what it is he means to not tell a
soul about this nobody
if this nobody brings it up from school
I don't say boo okay so after a certain
point the camera is like or arranged
that's why I would never want to bring
it up the longer we wait the longer
there's no there's no if you go to the
Board of Education and report this
they're gonna they're gonna call the
police and they're gonna call parents
and all that we don't do that we don't
do this here
I'm here to defend even the worst people
but I don't want to come in here with a
bunch of lies I need to know the truth
so that we can bend the truth so that we
can bend the truth so that's a president
of a teacher Association of a teacher
union in New Jersey
let's cut now to my interview with James
O'Keefe is a leader on this sort of
interview this sort of undercover
journalism really cool stuff let's go to
James James thank you for being here
great to be with you
so James by sheer coincidence or perhaps
divine providence we are recording this
interview on teacher appreciation day
and this is a beautiful irony because
the teachers unions do not appreciate
you very much right now we know the
Hamilton Teachers Education Association
president David Perry says that his job
is to bend the truth to defend the word
people from allegations of physical
abuse verbal threats against students he
admits to lying he admits to violating
state law and school policy and we only
know this because your outfit project
Veritas did an undercover investigation
to expose these corrupt leeches on
society James my first question do you
have cojones made of steel or titanium
how do you have the guts to go up
against some pretty bad hombres like
this and what sort of backlash do you
get when you release your investigations
how much time do you have I wrote I
talked about this ad nauseam in my book
American Pravda but I mean there's two
types of courage to fight a war like as
von Clausewitz argued there is the
physical courage to sort of you know
walk up the hill with a bayonet and then
there's moral courage and it's not me as
much as it is my team our brave cadre of
undercover journalists who spent a lot
of time in the field exposing these
crooks and fraudsters but this is an
unbelievable and and truly extraordinary
series of events two teachers union
presidents have been suspended the
Democrat governor of New Jersey and the
Democrat president of the state Senate
of New Jersey have both praised me and
Project Veritas I am NOT making that up
two Democrats have praised project
Veritas you heard that right calling for
bipartisan legislative hearings over
situations in these tapes where the
president of these unions Kathleen
Valencia was the other person she was
actually talking about an actual
incident not my undercover hypothetical
an actual incident where they actually
protected a teacher who had sex with a
teenage girl student and she said we
protected their pension nobody went to
jail David Perry said he protected
shoplifters drug abusing teachers he
said it's my job to defend the worst of
the worst and yes this is sort of the
Abu grave of the great society that for
so long this organization has never been
challenged its power tends to corrupt
and absolute power corrupts absolutely
and if you question if you take one
penny if you even dare to hold them
accountable you hate the children so
what you have is a you have a system
that has resisted any accountability and
has become systemic ly corrupt and don't
my word for it Dave Perry who's been
suspended president of the Trenton area
teachers union in New Jersey there says
that that is my job to defend the worst
of the worst and it just gets I mean I
can't make this up we just got a
restraining order over or returned
against us in the state of Michigan
Randy one hour ago this is breaking news
Randi Weingarten ahead of the AFT that's
the American Federation of Teachers in
Michigan has now been overruled by a
federal judge and we are releasing part
three tomorrow morning this is
incredible work because with regard to
these teachers unions in particular it's
this awful confluence of factors Samuel
Gompers great champion of labor FDR a
communist by my lights you know is
certainly a champion of labor both of
these men said that it would be absurd
to have government unions to have public
sector unions because it's totally
different than a private sector union
you have the government negotiating with
itself so there's no incentive to a
balance each other out there's no
incentive to keep costs down or to root
out the bad people you're it's the
government just negotiating with the
government when you add to that with the
teachers union case that you have these
children that you can demagogue that you
can say if you oppose us you hate the
kids just as you say you have this huge
opportunity for corruption oh what
forced you what made you set your sights
on this teacher union and with all of
the events that have transpired since
your investigation do you think we're
turning a corner with teachers unions in
this country with public sector unions
broadly I think we're experiencing a
great awakening as they say on social
media I think people are waking up
people are getting low cover you want to
say it I think things are Connie I
certainly is Hanyu is saying that I
think people are seeing the I mean st.
Augustine said the truth is like a lion
you just sort of let it out I believe in
video because I don't think words matter
anymore I think if I did what Ronan
Farrow did and Jane Mayer and I wrote an
article with sources no one would
believe me they call me a criminal they
call me a liar people would dismiss it
we have them on videotape and even the
this is truly extraordinary in New
Jersey which is I mean these are
right wingers the president of the state
Senate Sweeney is his name said that
giving the public employee unions I
remember these these guys were supposed
to they're in bed with the public
employee unions Sweeney says letting the
NJEA that's the Education Association
they're in New Jersey investigate itself
is like the fox guarding the henhouse
his words not mine so the the power of
cinema verite that is and I hope your
program plays some of these bits because
they were just unbelievable they're
actually talking about bending the truth
if you hit the kid he hit the kid it
looks like out of a Sopranos episode the
sorts of things these guys are saying
I mean it's so powerful and it's so
manifestly damning and hashtag me to
movement especially in light of these
Attorney General of New York resigning
and there's more coming and now they're
issuing restraining orders they're
issuing restraining orders against me
from releasing you can't make this stuff
up I mean have you ever heard of an
organization issuing a restraining order
against a journalist will you pose a
real threat CNN doesn't pose a threat
but you do I know and and and and I know
that we're hated I know they write a lot
of masks nasty things about us I know
that my wikipedia page has like 500
citations you know you know that I'm a
criminal and a hoaxster but at the end
of the day in the final analysis these
two presidents of the teachers unions
have been suspended and the governor of
New Jersey is calling for hearings and
Randi Weingarten is very scared of what
we're gonna release tomorrow because
tomorrow and now I can say this because
the judge has lifted the restraining
order tomorrow we have the documents
that's right we have the documents from
their filing cabinets and we're gonna
release them tomorrow we never we never
signed a nondisclosure agreement
we broke no laws we've got many lawyers
at Project Veritas we pay a lot of money
for all these lawyers we broke no laws
we have video we have sources we have
documents we have undercover footage
inside of the office and it will break
tomorrow morning at 7:00 a.m. 8:00 a.m.
Eastern Time we will break that video
that Randi warning did not want you to
see and I think to answer your question
I think we're experiencing a Great
Awakening I think people are waking up I
think people are realizing that this is
what happens when you have a media and
it's criminal what the media is doing in
this country not reporting on sacred
cows
because they like the idea of them I
assume you're talking about jewelry
that's the sacred cow you're talking
many sacred cows absolutely well you
bring up this point about video versus
print and it's true if you went out and
first of all if you tried to sell a
piece to the New York or Vanity Fair or
say the laughs you out of the room but
Ronan Farrow has done good journalism
and he's covered these things but he's
one of the lefties he's one of them
they'll let him in even if he's going
after Harvey Weinstein he's got plenty
of left cred he had a show on MSNBC's
from show business
his father probably as Frank Sinatra if
we're all being honest but you know he
comes from that world and you do not
they'll blackballed you there so what
you do you you put out the video you put
out video that is undeniable you you
it's who are you gonna believe me or
your lying eyes you've got the the video
right there and what do they say they
say oh that's so deceptively edited
that's the euphemism they use deceptive
don't believe your lyin eyes that's
deceptively edited well so are when you
put words together in a magazine article
they're actually selectively edited
together that's right it's hyperbole how
do you tell a story without putting
together concepts and words what video
is different video is a time slice of
reality in fact the parry video is 20
minutes long of like a 25 minute
interviewee we only cut out the bathroom
break and getting out of the car and
even if we didn't make a single cut
they'd still say but he came way he went
back into the office they'll always make
up some some obfuscation attempt but in
the final analysis these people have
been suspended and I think that's the
power video transfixes in a way that
words don't and the power of the truth
is it doesn't need to be explained you
know what we do is we expose the great
lies the great and and there's a
thousand people investigating the
National Rifle Association and nobody
looking into the public employee unions
with trillions of dollars of unfunded
liabilities with child abuse and if
you're a mathematician out there so we
didn't visit every office we visited a
very tiny fraction of them and we caught
two presidents of the teachers union
talking about covering up child abuse
well just do basic confidence interval
do basic statistics how many hundreds of
presidents have
teachers unions out there covered up
child abuse and that's why I don't think
they're gonna attack us anymore I think
you're actually going to see and mark my
words because tomorrow is our next video
you are actually going to see people
change their minds on the issue I I
wouldn't be surprised because your your
work has a quite a large effect and at
that point you know with the NRA the the
NRA exists to protect my
constitutionally protected civil rights
to defend those civil rights and they
have all the dogs going after them the
entire mainstream media apparatus are
going after them meanwhile the teachers
unions or what should be an illegal
entity an entity that even FDR as
left-wing and consequential president as
FDR said should never exist and those
guys are absolutely burglarizing our
wallets they're bankrupting our future
and they get off scot-free
oh you you've done a lot of these
investigations and they've turned the
corner on a lot of issues you've gone
after Planned Parenthood you've gone
after ACORN it if you had to pick some
of your favorite were the most
consequential or the ones you're
happiest you went after the best enemies
you could have what what do you think
they would be well I searched Hill said
that if you're making enemies it means
you've stood for something I think that
the to address that part of it I think
as Rush Limbaugh has said to be hated is
a difficult thing for people to get over
but I think in this day and age to be
hated as a sign of respect and a sign of
success Iran those are two very good
cigar smoking conservative men through
both of that's all they're both they
both share that in common but I think
that's one of the things that people
always ask us at Project Veritas is oh
my god you know you go through so much
just despise from the mainstream media
people hate you so much and I would say
that that's the toughest thing the
psychological get get used to that is to
is to be hated for exposing unreality I
would say the thing we're most proud of
is probably the investigation we did I
would say the two ones that we're most
proud of here the recent one on Twitter
exposing shadow banning and getting
Twitter lobbyists grilled before
Congress about them shadow banning
people I think that's a big deal because
I think social media companies have
become the
big trusts of the early 20th 20th
century the the new the new trusts are
the social media companies if they have
the power to censor and shadow ban as
their people said into our hidden camera
what you see in here then they can
literally augment reality they can
affect your this program is being
broadcast on social media right now and
if they can shadow ban that and by the
way yeah mine are being broadcast right
now they are doing that we I need visual
confirmation again if I just put out
anonymous sources no one would believe
me they would call me a liar I don't
have the power that Ronan Farrow has in
the culture I have to get visual
confirmation I have to get verbal I have
to get the people's lips in the camera
saying they're doing it we'll do it
that's the first the second thing that
we're most proud of is the video on Bob
creamer that that Trump cited in the
presidential debates talking about
inciting violence at Trump rallies with
all the Muller stuff going on we
actually have Hillary Clinton's
operatives on hidden camera remember
that one they were saying we incite
violence at Trump rallies we commit
voter fraud the videos were mentioned in
the debates in front of 75 million
people it prompted Bob creamer to resign
Scott Coville was fired and they're
suing me but in any just world in any
just world in a system of equal justice
under the law Bob Mueller would be
investigating that because they admit to
laundering money from the Clinton
campaign through a series of
subcontractors to make it look like
Trump people are violent and the Russia
stuff has no evidence and they're still
going so we live in a very unjust world
premise number one or the only way we
can break through or Iraq beat scissors
is through the power of video and an
immobilizing of Free People bypassing
the mainstream media while facing
lawsuits and incarceration it's truly an
extraordinary series events but we will
win we will win because we have them and
we have the truth on our side and we're
releasing part three of our teachers
union expose tomorrow morning which
Randi Weingarten did not want you to see
and you're doing journalism I that's the
basic point of it you're doing
journalism in the real scheme of things
in the way that these roles are supposed
to go reporters are supposed to be rats
they're supposed to go
and get the stories that they're hard to
find and you got to go undercover and
you're you're exposing those stories CNN
doesn't do that
a recent survey from the Media Research
Center shows that over the last three
months 45% of Network News TV coverage
of Donald Trump has been about policies
or issues a full 65 percent have been
about porn stars and expensive tables at
the EPA and 91 percent of that coverage
total has been negative 91 percent of
the evaluative comments just commentary
about that but where is the
investigation where or is the actual
work of journalism it's happening
because you're doing it you and very few
other people do you have any hope for
the future of journalism in the United
States do you think that this edifice of
CNN ABC Washington Post that that is
gonna crack the basically the Democrat
communications firms that pretend to be
news outlets do you think that that will
crack and that real journalism will come
back up as a serious force in American
politics or is it just gonna be you and
a video camera and a few other people
trying to get stories out that the
mainstream media are gonna keep covering
up I think it I have a lot of hope in
fact I spend every day of my life
fighting cynicism and hopelessness that
pervades our country when I speak in
front of audiences when I recruit people
there is a lot of hope but people need
to understand something very clearly
this requires a tremendous amount of
moral courage to do this sort of thing
I'm not I'm not trying to Pat myself on
the back here I've got a team of dozens
of people that surround me that are very
selfless they don't have a byline
they're out there in the field they're
like germs they're everywhere you don't
know it but they're recording waste
fraud and abuse and they're gonna make
you the unwilling internet celebrity if
you're doing something wrong but I think
you know I've been incarcerated I've
been jailed I've been sued I've got 15
lawsuits against me right now I've had
the restraining order against me in the
state of Michigan which allows the media
to go
O'Keefe has a restraining order against
him in federal court and then the
journalists go oh that's controversial
and they create this this this nexus of
controversy and they pollute the
airwaves and it's not that these
journalists are are bad people I
wouldn't even say many of them are bad
journalists I
they're part of a system supported
propaganda function that does what Noam
Chomsky calls manufacturers consent and
it's not just because it's political its
economic they're not going to disrupt
the applecart upset the people in the
intelligence agencies and in the deep
state and in government and the people
who control at least they think control
the decision-making authority in these
government agencies another quick
example is a lot of people were afraid
to report our abuses inside the Hillary
Clinton campaign that led to
resignations because they were afraid
that when Hillary was elected she would
regulate them when she was inevitably
elected and she was inevitably or
invariably this was like a natural thing
that was gonna happen they were afraid
this is back in October of 2016 that
when she was elected that she was going
to retaliate and and that's the Banana
Republic and and my point to you is that
the hope comes in the moral courage the
hope comes in in that David versus
Goliath in the courtroom or in the court
of public opinion says I don't care if
you brand-new with this scarlet letter
go ahead and jail me go ahead make my
day shut me down
put me in jail hold me in contempt of
court because I'm gonna release this
video tomorrow morning and the more that
we do that in other words the more that
we double down instead of back down as
corny as that might sound we will win
the problem is and you're not gonna like
hearing this a lot of people in the
conservative movement are to blame you
have to grow a pair and you have to
stand behind the people who are fighting
and the moment you condemn someone who
is they will jump over that like white
on rice it's exactly right this is a
point I try to make on the show pretty
frequently is that it's very easy to to
sit and talk or whatever and tweet and
have opinions but when people are out
there when your own guys are out there
fighting there they're on your team
they're fighting for your political
goals you've got to give them cover
we're not were political partisans here
we're doing some of the truth right
fighting for the truth I was attacked
because I didn't condemn Alex Jones the
other day by someone on Twitter and I
was it I was advised by people smarter
than meaning me don't even engage people
but here's the thing with the rules of
engagement are changed the reason I
don't condemn people is because I know
how they're gonna play that they're
gonna
create a headline they're gonna cause
angst and division right we're fighting
an asymmetrical war for truth here and
the rules of engagement are different
and if you want to enter the arena see
what it's like to go out in the field
and do journalism and see what it's like
to have the establishment attack you you
have to have the backs of people who are
out in the arena as Teddy Roosevelt
would say it don't condemn them
don't criticize them support it and you
have the courage to stand behind those
who do and they ask me when people ask
they'll say what do you have a liqu
shows is a good example because he's you
know frequently shirtless and yelling
about things and they say what do you
say say something mean about Alex Jones
this what do I care about Alex Jones
what do I care what are you asking me
for what well there are they're not
bigger issues in the country or you have
you not watched any james o'keefe videos
are you not look I would much rather
talk about teachers union presidents
that are talking about violating laws
and defending teachers who abuse
students then what a radio host says
someday on his radio show get your
priorities in order absolutely right and
I got a say on that Banana Republic
point you're absolutely right this when
you see CNN actually said they did a
commercial where they said we are a
banana or something like that I could
you didn't get it quite right but they
are they are a banana and you're doing
real journalism and I can't wait to see
the new video it's just really keep up
the great work well I'll let you go back
to toppling the left wing edifice but
it's really good stuff and I can't wait
to see the new video stay tuned tomorrow
morning comes out and you'll see it all
over the internet thanks James thanks
james o'keefe coming to us from that
hidden project Veritas bunker somewhere
in the hills of Pakistan or something
like that so we've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube we're running too
late already as it is we have a lot of
mailbag to get to so let's get to it oh
do you hear that oh it's like bells
chiming birds singing it's almost time
for the next episode of the conversation
featuring me little ol Michael Knowles
on Tuesday May 15th at 5:30 Eastern 2:30
Pacific I will be taking all of your
questions easing your anxiety answering
you live on air every query that is
burned in your heart will be resolved
best of all it's an extra hour-long dose
of little ol me I promise I will
be wearing pants even if it looks like
I'm wearing pants they'll have added
that in post-production
Alicia Krause will be there too and
that'll be very nice she's a lovely gal
this month's episode will stream live on
Daily wires YouTube and Facebook pages
it will be free for everyone to watch
but only subscribers can ask the
questions to ask questions as a
subscriber log in to our website daily
wire.com head over to the conversation
page and watch the live stream after
that just start typing into the daily
wire chat box I will answer questions as
they come in for an entire hour
subscribe to get your questions answered
by me little ole me Michael Knowles on
Tuesday May 15th 5:30 Eastern 2:30
Pacific join the conversation you know
what you get at the Daily wire don't you
you know what you get a daily wired I
come you get all the shows you get you
know can ask questions and all that come
on guys you didn't even know woe to you
who didn't know you thought you'd
survive the Iran deal being shredded you
thought you'd survive to all of it the
hostages coming back from Korea you said
why don't you just subscribe I don't
need to get my leftist here's tumblr
they just decapitated most of Isis and
then you drown don't get caught in that
how many times do I've to tell you get a
leftist here's tumblr to protect
yourself and your family we've got a lot
of mailbag questions stay tuned we'll be
right back
I have five minutes to answer these
questions so you know what we're gonna
go okay we're gonna start now here we go
James hey Michael do you believe the New
Deal and it's in Keynesian economics
extended the Great Depression or helped
to end it more quickly an extent that's
a great question it extended the
depression it extended the depression
that's it there very few people would
seriously argue otherwise anymore very
few people it quite clearly extended the
Great Depression FDR prolonged this
awful depression and people of people
who are not economists have taken very
inaccurate conclusions from that
experience a good study came out in 2004
from UCLA economists Harold Cole and Lee
Ohanian and it showed that the New Deal
stymied economic recovery for seven full
years Ohanian who is the vice chairman
of UCLA's econ department a wrote quote
why the Great Depression lasted so long
has always been a great mystery and
because we never really knew the reason
we have always worried whether we would
have another ten to fifteen year
economic slump we found that a relapse
isn't likely unless lawmakers gum it up
with ill-conceived stimulus policies so
what they conclude here is that
anti-competition and pro-labor measures
that FDR push that went into effect in
June 1933 are the most responsible for
extending the Great Depression FDR
believed that the Depression was caused
by competition and because competition
lowers prices sometimes sometimes it
lowers wages other times it doesn't so
he allowed businesses to collude
basically he said he promised that there
would not be antitrust threats here he
showed caved in to wage demands so wages
rose a full 25% above market value in 11
key industries after the New Deal wages
were 25% higher than otherwise would
have been and unemployment was also 25%
higher than it would have been prices
across 19 industries were artificially
high same figure about 25 percent 23%
higher than they would have been at
demand had stalled and gross national
product dropped around the same amount
about 27 percent below where it should
have been but when you start tinkering
in the economy especially on those
huge levels you're gonna have terrible
effects the another extraordinarily slow
recovery have occurred under Barack
Obama's watch when he decided to tinker
with one-sixth of the economy to waste
gazillions of dollars on stimulus
policies that didn't do anything
yet those who do not learn from the past
or bound to repeat it hopefully we can
start learning from the past I see an
awakening happening in the United States
led by Donald Trump and Kanye West and
everybody in the middle so maybe we'll
finally learn from the past from Ben hey
brother Michael seems you finally got
some praise by ben shapiro how does it
feel I know you get a lot of religious
questions hopefully you can read this
one if you could give someone Dead or
Alive truth serum who would it be
I'd give Ben truth serum to see if you
really meant it because if he really
meant it if Ben actually is giving
compliments on my show or giving me
praise will know that the apocalypse is
happening we will know that forget you
know peace and Korea nuclear Iran all of
these big you know crazy things the if
Ben starts complimenting my show that is
the greatest evidence the rapture is
coming make your peace with your Creator
next question from Evan dear Michael
historian extraordinaire and thorn in
the side of one Ben Shapiro I'm from
Pennsylvania and at school I had a
decent amount of Pennsylvania history do
you think that the founder of PA William
Penn would today be considered one of
these trust-fund leftist kids that wants
socialism and or would he be boxed into
another category I only bring this up
because of his great experiment of
creating a perfect society in the awful
city of Philadelphia bless blesses on
your nuptials Evan yeah Philly certainly
isn't the City of Brotherly Love I was
just there it's it's not the perfect
Society
so look obviously William Penn was a
pacifist Quaker and actually was I think
the first person to propose a version of
the European Union so his thinking had
some problems he didn't have the right
idea about many things but I don't want
to lump him in with all the crazy lefty
hedge tread trust fund kids that we see
on campuses today he's writing in the
16th century 17th century rather he grew
up under Oliver Cromwell King Charles
the first was beheaded
when penn was a child he lived through
smallpox through a plague epidemic he
lived through the Great Fire of 1666 his
circumstances shaped him and I I don't
really mind so much people who embrace
bad ideas the first time around when
there are all these awful things
happening society is shifting in such
massive massive ways as it was in the
17th century and so they try out some
new idea or they're brought towards some
new idea I mind people who insist on
embracing bad ideas after they've been
shown to fail I don't even I don't
really even mind people who embraced
Marx when Marx was writing shortly
thereafter I'd you know people try out
new ideas when they're in fashion I
minds the people who were Che Guevara
t-shirts today because we've seen the
horrors and misery and destruction that
those political and economic systems
have wrought
if you in the face of all of that
evidence they're gonna wear your Che
Guevara t-shirt then you deserve shame
and you should reconsider your choices
but for those guys the first time around
you know I think we can have a little
historical sympathy or empathy for them
and I I always hate looking back and
criticizing the people who helped create
our society I find it's like spitting on
the shoulders of giants
you know we're standing on the shoulders
of giants and we think we're flying
we're not flying even if we can see a
little further than them so I don't want
to be ungrateful toward them next
question from Norman
Norman's senior where is this rising
political star Knowles thank you very
much today I heard ben shapiro express
an erroneous view that you are a unique
you are uniquely poised to rebut as a
catholic in his interview with jordan
peterson been asserted that the
enlightenment was opposed to tribalism
because Enlightenment thinkers are
individualist rather than collectivists
you and I know that the Enlightenment
and the Reformation before it which
broke away from the universal Church
actually contributed to a resurgence of
tribalism in the form of nationalism
some Enlightenment thinkers became
individualist sore rationalists as you
call them others became collectivists do
you think ben shapiro really believes
his tidy historical dichotomy or is he
promoting it because he thinks it is
politically useful for conservatives to
think the
way I don't know why Ben is suggesting
that I thought was a good interview and
actually as I see it both views are
correct
both what Ben said and the legitimate
critiques that you've made of that as
Ben said the Enlightenment does consider
itself opposed to tribalism it does
propose itself as an opposition to
tribalism as a universalism is basically
saying we're going to transcend so much
and have these universal principles that
we can all access particularly through
our reason that this there's raising up
of Reason rationalism now you and I know
in reality the Enlightenment just
wrought a lot of new tribalism
it brought a lot of nationalism and
communism even individualism all of the
isms not all of the Enlightenment's are
made equal the Enlightenment in Scotland
was much better than the Enlightenment
in France with all the guillotines a
good I think a case in point here is on
why the Enlightenment broadly isn't so
great and or why it's solving problems
and not the right way or it ultimately
why it failed
you can see it in the 20th century moral
philosophers Robert Nozick and John
Rawls so Nozick let's call him the
broadly conservative point of view
speaking broadly Nozick defines justice
from a position of inalienable rights
defending inalienable rights
Rawls defines justice from a position of
equality with respect to needs so we
hear the kind of lefty positions here
and lefties do tend to like roles a lot
these appear to be opposing positions
don't they the inalienable rights or the
equality with respect to needs they
appear to be opposing really they're
drawing from the exact same confused
premises so Nozick traces entitlement to
all legitimate acts of original
acquisition even though there's no such
thing as there's no evidence for
original legitimate acquisition in the
history of the world did as the United
States acquired legitimately or did we
take it from some Indians and did those
Indians take it from other Indians and
did they you know where do we really see
these perfectly pristine legitimate acts
of acquisition roles for his part traces
equality in respect to needs to
any rational person would choose for
society if he were behind a veil of
ignorance and couldn't decide his own
position in society so this is you hear
people talk about this is the main thing
people hear about with John Rawls is the
veil of ignorance if I if I could
construct a society and say ok I I don't
know which position I'm gonna have I
would want one that's quite equitable in
reality even though we're looking at
this as the right and the left these are
two sides of the same coin
both of these pretend that we come into
the world as atomized individuals
without any community or duty or
conception of the good for man that is a
product of the Enlightenment that comes
to us from the Enlightenment and it's
just wrong now but why did the
Enlightenment do this the Enlightenment
is trying to recover something that is
being lost in modernity it's and and is
being lost from the moment of the
Protestant revolution most particularly
it's trying to recreate ancient
conceptions of virtues the the unified
moral authority that was in the church
before it cracked up and it's trying to
do that by other means it's trying to
recover Martin Luther rejected Aristotle
rejected this classical moral framework
an ethical framework so it's trying to
recover it by other means how do we get
the good without God
how do we get this ethical framework how
do we get this Christendom without
without the things that made it
Christendom and it failed so you get
sometimes you hear the people when you
go so far left you end up right and if
when you end up so far right you end up
left when you end up so so far left you
become a communist sort of authoritarian
sort of I mean monarchist romão knows
right and you you're kind of floating
between these things this is where it
comes from because the Enlightenment as
a project I think failed the question is
what do we do now how do we pick up the
pieces there was a book that we passed
around here a few months ago that's
really really good on this after virtue
by Alistair McIntyre and it tries to
deal with this problem if you have a
cracked moral framework what are you
supposed to do okay do we have any time
for one more we got to get out of here
we got time for one more okay we're
gonna do one more the the okay mr. Noles
from Justin I recently found out my
girlfriend is pro-abortion she's neck
deep in a four year social science
degree so maybe this shouldn't surprise
me but she's a Christian every time we
argue about a moral issue she says that
all sin is equal and no one is to judge
what would your rebuttal to this be I
don't want to stone women get an
abortion I just want it to stop
yeah good idea sincerely Justin okay so
to begin I've heard this before to all
sin is exactly the same and you know so
don't criticize me for supporting
killing a bunch of little babies all sin
is not equal it is not evil we hear this
from John John writes Saint John writes
quote all wrongdoing is sin but there is
sin which is not mortal so just from
that line alone we know that not all sin
is made equal not all sin is mortal all
wrongdoing is sin but there is sin which
is not mortal therefore there are
different types of sin st. Paul writes
about this st. Paul says that there is
the possibility of losing salvation of
being cut off and therefore we must
remain in Christ lest salvation be lost
and we know from James that not all sin
causes salvation to be lost even though
all salvation can be lost James writes
quote we all stumble in many ways if we
all stumble in many ways not all sin is
mortal not all sin causes salvation to
be lost there are different kinds of sin
so there are two points here one is sin
sin is bad all sin is very very very bad
now on the flip side we don't want to
downplay how bad all sin is we don't
want to downplay lusting in your heart
on the other flipside we don't want to
downplay the seriousness of certain sins
like abortion so to say oh we all sin
abortion you know it's the same thing as
stealing a pack of bubblegum and you
know it's it who can judge you no really
that is a way to ignore the moral
seriousness of abortion so I think it's
a clever crafty little way to try to get
out of it but it just isn't true it's
not supported by the scripture it's
certainly not supported by sacred
tradition and it's not supported by our
own moral reasoning okay on that note
I've got to get out of here we're
running way way late thank you for being
here I'm Michael Knoll this is the
Michael Knowles show have a good weekend
try to survive all the Kofi Fae don't OD
on it and I'll see you on Monday
you
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you